we have this idea Assad non-bonded
quadratics can more or less be dealt
with just like our mic works that's nice
however have a look at example 2 you
can't do all of them like this for
negative 11 and 6 is there a single
common factor I can pull out of all of
them and says no maybe because of this
guy what a jerk I told you they often
end up as prime numbers
okay in 11th divide through by 11 in one
neither of which is any use to us so
what will we do here this is important
there's a couple of different ways we
can go about this I'm going to show you
how I do it and you probably think wait
why did he do that for
I'll explain it as we go but I wonder if
you can try and work out what's going on
with this next line I am going to take
this little guy here I'm going to break
it into two pieces - 11 K so this is
like writing by this K - K - K - K -
another 11 times and I can group them up
in any way that I like right now they're
just sitting in one group I'm going to
fit Mop Institute for reasons that will
become clear in there I'm going to spit
the mulling like is
are you okay with that I have just
written this in two parts rather than
one minus xi k minus 3k minus EI k
they're the same thing just looked at in
two part other one now having done this
I've just turned this question from
wonder we didn't know how to do into one
that you do know how to do think back to
lessons I gave you lots of questions
where you had four terms in Aurora what
was your main strategy for dealing with
all four you would pair them up
furniture you say okay is there a common
factor between these two and in this
case there is it's gonna be cake what do
you get left with when you have
deviceport yes then you look at the
other pair and you say is there a common
factor and the interest there is I could
save two but in this case I'm actually
going to say negative minus two okay
when I check out that what will like a
definite oh that's suspicious so you can
see I've transformed the problems oh did
you how to into one that I didn't have
I can do one more thank you I do I'm
going to take out the four K minus 3
because it's a comment take it out the
front and then that leaves you is Kane
yelling - - they're Zemeckis okay
now I'm not finished with these
questions yeah remember the part I so a
bit mysterious to you was I chose to
break apart the minus 11 K in a very
particular way I chose to do it like
this now why did I choose negative 3 and
negative 8 look at the very first line
look at the numbers where do you see the
connection making what do you reckon
they're like
ah before I just paid attention to this
number you see that those are give me 24
need your support vehicle give me six
these will give me negative 30 yeah we
only paid attention to the last one but
here because this guy answered right is
now a different number right not one
anymore now you have to pay attention to
both of them does that make sense
in fact you always were paying attention
to both it's just that when it was one
it didn't make a difference right one
times negative 30 still making it there
one times negative 24 still they're
twins massive so you're paying attention
to both of them 4 times 6 is 24 so now I
think of my care numbers I look think
about 6 figure out what pair of numbers
will multiply to negative 24
as I project we think I hear my two
numbers
why don't I choose negative 3 and
negative 8 and not plus 3 and plus it
supplies together then also network yeah
that's right well I can use them just as
easily make 24 and also I can build them
out of this - 11k to see that this is
not plus 11 case - so that's why all of
these are bigger
ok so what you're thinking of these
remember before I asked you to write
down a guide for what you do with this
your figure a pair of numbers that adds
to be multiplies to see everything is an
extra number of the front this is what
you're dealing with and that's why it
was being seated the a was hiding okay
so go ahead and write this maybe up on
the side to factorize an on monic
quadratic like ax squared plus BX plus C
you still want a pair of numbers that
adds up to be you still want that you're
still looking for something out of add
up to negative 11 or liner where is okay
but you don't want them to just multiply
to give C you want your pair of numbers
to multiply to give a see this product
a C in this case it was 24 and just 24
okay let's do another table and see if
you could do this um this double thing
for B and the next thing I'm going to
show you is let's just do that work to
do this or that base can I rub this off
yeah
if you devil yes going going okay this
time remember I came up with the numbers
negative three and negative eight but
it's not on you to help you so did this
sucker the six what is that did I get it
right yeah okay keeps W squared minus
seventeen dollars plus five again seeing
a really even reasonably easy number
that I think we can manage so we want
them to add up the pair numbers you're
kicking off with them to add up to add
up to negative 17 we want the pair of
numbers to multiply to give which to the
side which is say okay so the pair of
know that multiplies to 30 multiplies
the third think about your factors are
35 threw them in your head it's going to
be negative 15 and negative 2 that'll
work point the negative you're careful
and give you these two so let's go ahead
will write it acclaim $6 u squared
negative 15 W okay yeah this is what I
got this is how we decided to split okay
now we're about to find out if we split
it correctly I've got pairs right so
I'll look at the first here we go are
there any common factors 3 and W are
both common factors in it so in which
neurons I'll pull the 3w out what does
that leave this guy with what's left
behind
but this one's left behind now remember
if we've done is right we want to get
some commonality as we go and do the
next pair have a look is there any
common factor here
now does it look like there is but in
order to get to here I am going to
faster I something out namely negative
one because look do you see how kind of
- psyche but I'm plus live man oh wait a
spotlight so if I take out a factor of
negative one it'll switch the signs
around like this so 2w minus five is an
object how many of these objects do I
have here I have three W of them how
many do I have here I have minus one of
them this is the object that's just this
label okay so now I can provide your
industry I'll take that common factor of
2w minus 5 that's the object we'll take
it out what Brett behind this is why
even though that one does it make a
difference if I don't write it it's
still correct I like to put the minus
one there because when I factorize on
the next line it reminds me hey there is
actually an object to use there's like
an extra bit along the end a lot of
students when they don't write that they
forget to write another Bigfoot okay now
just to finish before you get going on
those questions there they are
okay remember we carry with us tree
numbers negative 15 minus 15 W and minus
2w I put minus in there first and then 1
2 after does it matter which way we put
them through let's find out if I wrote
down 6w squared and just by chance I
wrote down which is the opposite
direction I show you so slaughter ground
can I still solve this question time to
do something with it I can't write how
to look at this time my first pair is a
different pairing is there a common
factor what's that behind that looks
familiar doesn't it
what about here is there a colored back
only mine I'm going to choose to take
out - I could take up positive by that
it was convenient to me but this time is
what could be in today - because it
leaves me weird so one of the nice
things about this particular strategy is
that we ever way you go okay you almost
can't screw it up you still end up here
question stayed up happy